[Música]
chila se enfrenta tal vez a una de las
decisiones más trascendentales en su
historia reciente los ciudadanos deberán
aprobar o no la propuesta de una nueva
constitución un borrador que actualiza
la carta magna de este país suramericano
e incluye temas de coyuntura actual como
por ejemplo los temas medioambientales
también incluye algunos reclamos
sociales que vienen de muchas décadas
atrás como por ejemplo la representación
de las minorías la diversidad los
pueblos indígenas y una propuesta de un
nuevo sistema de producción económica el
debate y los pedidos por una nueva
constitución vienen desde hace varios
años pero se incrementaron en el 2019 y
ha sido un argumento pan para agudizar
la ya profunda polarización que vive la
sociedad chilena en torno a este tema es
por este motivo que la decisión que van
a tener los chilenos el fin de semana
genera muchísima expectativa y por
supuesto también llena de incertidumbre
sobre lo que significa esta aprobación o
no de esta constitución para chile
patricia luna nuestra corresponsal la
france24 en la ciudad de santiago
un panorama general de como el país que
ya está en cuenta regresiva para el
inicio de la votación enfrenta este
momento histórico
tranquilidad la que se respira en las
calles de chile tras el cierre de las
campañas de la prueba y el rechazo en un
acto completamente multitudinario que
llenó las calles del centro de santiago
se despidió la campaña del apruebo con
la participación de figuras culturales
asociadas a ideas progresistas en el
país grandes grupos musicales un
ambiente festivo y también los voceros
de la prueba que son figuras políticas
conocidas en el país y también de ex
constituyentes con un tono completamente
diferente se despedían los partidarios
del rechazo en un acto en la cima de una
colina muy reconocida en santiago el
cerro san cristóbal en un carácter mucho
más ciudadanos sin la participación de
figuras políticas reconocidas ni ex
constituyentes pero sí con el
protagonismo de una gran enorme bandera
chilena de grandes dimensiones que se
desplegó en torno a esta colina y
también se entregaba en banderas
chilenas a todas las personas que
acudieron a este acto que fue mucho
masivo que el acto del apruebo las
encuestas publicadas como marca la ley
extra electoral en chile- 15 días antes
del plebiscito dan como favoritos en su
mayoría a la opción del rechazo pero
todas las opciones están abiertas no
sólo por la forma masiva en la que los
partidarios de la prueba salieron el
jueves por la noche a las calles sino
también porque estos serán las primeras
elecciones desde 2012 con voto
obligatorio lo que mueve a una cantidad
de electores cuyo comportamiento es
totalmente desconocido todo puede
ocurrir mucha incertidumbre también
espera presencia la que se vive en el
país a pocas horas de un proceso
electoral que podría cambiar la historia
de chile para siempre
todas las opciones están sobre la mesa
para los chilenos para esta votación a
lo largo de estos meses ha habido un
bombardeo informativo sobre la propuesta
de este documento pero también ha sido
la excusa perfecta para desinformar a
los chilenos y también una forma de
manipular verdaderamente qué tan
informados están los chilenos sobre el
borrador de esta constitución es el
chileno un votante responsable ha
estudiado el documento antes de
enfrentarse a esta elección sabe lo que
tiene verdaderamente en sus manos porque
se convirtió esta elección en una
especie de referendo a la gestión del
presidente gabriel boric cuáles son los
escenarios probables para chile' si el
resultado de este plebiscito es la
aprobación o si el resultado es la no
aprobación de este borrador chile define
en cierta manera su futuro en pocos
escenarios la responsabilidad de una
sociedad pesaba tanto para definir el
rumbo de un país el referendo
constitucional en chile- es nuestro tema
de análisis hoy en el debate de france
24 y para analizar este tema hemos
invitado
josé ossandón él es abogado ex
convencional constituyente y también
hemos invitado a claudia barahona chang
que ya es miembro de la comisión
política del partido socialista ambos se
encuentran en la ciudad de santiago en
la capital de chile para participar en
este programa les recuerdo que ustedes
también hacen parte de esta conversación
pueden dejar todas sus preguntas y
comentarios también en nuestras redes
sociales estamos en twitter también
estamos en instagram en facebook en
donde no se encuentran como france24
bajo ese arroba santi logo que es mi
cuenta personal la etiqueta se la
recuerdo es numerar el debate efe 24
también en youtube ustedes pueden seguir
la señal en streaming y pueden
participar en el chat en vivo también
aprovecho para saludar a las personas
que nos están escuchando a través del
podcast todos los contenidos de nuestro
programa los pueden encontrar en
diferentes plataformas en app el podcast
en spotify deezer y tuning
y bueno pues comienzo dándole la palabra
a claudia en la ciudad de santiago en la
capital chilena punto de partida a
claudia bienvenida al programa el punto
de partida es la pregunta con la que me
gusta tantear la opinión de los de los
invitados al programa y cómo llega chile
a este escenario a este plebiscito cómo
está el país ante esta coyuntura porque
más o menos lo que ha llevado a realizar
esta esta propuesta de constitución lo
tenemos más o menos claro por este
malestar social que estaba presentando
estaba presentando el país pero lo que
preocupa ahora es cómo está llegando el
país a este escenario del plebiscito
yo diría que el país
está llegando con
con alegría es algo que se esperaba en
algo que ha podido tantear el terreno
viajando por chile y sobre todo
recorriendo la región metropolitana es
algo que pueblo espera con ansias
porque es una propuesta que cambia el
estado de ser de un estado
muy cortado en el accionar social vamos
a tener una constitución
que declara el estado social democrático
del derecho entonces eso obviamente
beneficia a los sectores más
desprotegidos de nuestro país y
entendiendo que acá las riquezas están
súper mal
distribuidas el 80% de la población
aproximadamente vive con el sueldo
mínimo por lo tanto esta nueva
constitución es una nueva propuesta para
poder mejorar el país no solamente
económicamente sino que también
socialmente donde los derechos de cada
ciudadano y ciudadana van a poder ser
efectivos y manuel también en la ciudad
de santiago bienvenido al programa punto
de partida como llega desde su
perspectiva a este país a este
plebiscito cómo está el país de cara a
esta coyuntura es muy importante lo que
está en juego en este momento para los
chilenos
bueno con mucha esperanza pero bueno
esperanza de tener una buena propuesta
constitución porque la verdad creo que
este borrador está muy lejos de lo que
la gente espera da necesariamente yo
creo que tenemos que dar una nueva
constitución pero este proyecto deja
mucho que desear tiene gravísimos
problemas en cuanto a materias que son
muy relevantes como por ejemplo la
seguridad en términos de derechos
sociales quedaron muy mal redactado no
está segura absolutamente nada porque
son de carácter progresivo y vas es
baires verde la cantidad de dinero que
tenga el estado para financiar estos
derechos por lo tanto no genera ningún
cambio inmediato su implementación va a
ser sumamente lenta no sólo eso sino que
tiene graves problemas de redacción y
por sobre todo un sistema político que
es único en el mundo inentendible ni
siquiera un sistema parlamentario ni
siquiera un sistema presidencial lo
vuelva a generar con muchísimos
problemas abre espacio también para que
el presidente la república pueda
gobernar por regreso por una estrecha
cantidad de meses sin un complot de un
tribu de una cuarte constitucional claro
entre otras materias que son su mano por
lo tanto creo que desde el punto de
vista jurídico ni siquiera político esta
propuesta de constitución es realmente
mala y aún más creo que afecta
especialmente a los más desposeídos
porque el exgeneral derechos a elección
en muchos los derechos manuel continuó
con usted para hacer la ronda a la
inversa ya le doy la palabra a claudia
en unos minutos esta constitución busca
reemplazar la constitución vigente que
hay en chile que data de 1980 tuvo
cambios y algunas modificaciones en el
2005 y en el 2009 pero carga con un gran
pecado y es haber sido hecha durante la
dictadura de augusto pinochet
hay consenso en que el país necesita una
nueva constitución podría haberse tomado
esta constitución de 1980 como base y
haber simplemente hecho modificaciones
un poco más profundas y añadir unos
temas más de la actualidad como lo
mencionaba yo temas por ejemplo
medioambientales
bueno sin duda yo creo que hoy día la
mayoría de los sectores de moderados
tanto de derecha como izquierda hay un
consenso de que se requiere una nueva
constitución políticamente una
constitución agotada pero al menos el
sector que yo representé parte también
de la centroizquierda consideramos que
este proyecto no cumple con las
expectativas
genera problemas severos entrega un
consentimiento indígena para la toma de
decisiones que son muy trascendentales
aumentar el nivel de burocracia aumenta
el gasto público según cálculo a cerca
de 18 mil millones de dólares lo cual
nadie sabe aunque se va a obtener a que
alguien dinero a efectos de financiar
esta propuesta por lo tanto yo creo que
efectivamente
quitamos una nueva constitución pero una
buena no es un claudia cuál es su
opinión también el consenso está usted
de acuerdo en que la constitución de
1980 ya era momento dejarla de lado
renovar la carta magna pero que esta
constitución
si recoge todas estas demandas sociales
y todas estos requerimientos que
necesita el país en la actualidad
sí por supuesto o sea hay que cambiar la
actual constitución como tú muy bien lo
decía esta constitución fue hecha entre
cuatro paredes fue algo que nos impuso
la dictadura militar es una constitución
que le abrió la puerta y se instaló en
nuestra sociedad el neoliberalismo
y
está todo lo que fue la revuelta social
fue el cansancio de aquello porque la
constitución actual lo que hace es que
el estado sea subsidiario no garantiza
derechos básicos como una vivienda digna
derecho a la salud por ejemplo que
efectivamente la persona tenga derecho a
la salud y no a derecho a elegir si
metiendo en isapres o metiendo en fonasa
porque si no tengo plata me puedo morir
esperando una atención digna yo creo que
esta constitución si recoge todas las
demandas sociales
y efectivamente va a haber que ir a ir
acomodándolo porque esta es la
constitución es un marcado de cancha
donde las leyes chilenas se tienen que
desarrollar para poder llevar esto a
cabo
a la derecha
he echado opuesto a los cambios sociales
por más de 40 años claro por lo tanto yo
le preguntaría al es constituyente
manuel ossandón
que pudiera explicar
y significa eso de que necesita ser una
buena constitución y una constitución
buena porque a mi parecer
y a la mayoría del pueblo
esta constitución es un gran avance para
la sociedad chilena
claro claro después de moler la palabra
a manuel manuel que le responde usted a
claudia
bueno muy simple en primer lugar yo creo
que tanto escuelas probablemente claudia
la dirección a la gravedad del de las
malas prácticas
internamente y de la mala redacción que
tiene el texto ella habla de la derecha
pero no hace mención a que parte
importante de personeros izquierda de la
democracia cristiana del partido por la
democracia que fue cercana al partido
socialista incluso el partido realizar
un expreso el candidato a presidente
están en contra de esta propuesta porque
es una propuesta que está lejos de
cualquier atractivo común tiene una
pésima reacción jurídica entregó un
poder desmedido a poder le inviten a
decisiones por el consentimiento
indígena es algo que es acá
prácticamente lo está consagrado en
ninguna parte del mundo en que va a
generar problemas severos en términos
políticos por un sistema político que
también le va a permitir a un presidente
con mayoría a ser una especie de
emperador sea izquierda o derecha y con
una serie de problemas que están
realmente graves por otra parte en
cuanto a temas de cambios quiero decirle
a claudia que al menos el sector que yo
represento renovación nacional si es
cubrir puesto al menos la parte más
liberal a aprobar el proyecto de chile y
incluso si tú haces un cálculo de
coincidencia matemática entre el texto
que proponía battelle al final de su
mandato con la constitución vigente que
además está firmada por el presidente
lagos bien buena con los socialistas
tienen una conciencia de alrededor de un
94 por tiempo o sea que con el nuevo
borrador casi no hay coincidencias por
lo tanto
hay que hay que ser más más precisos no
puedes hablar solamente de la derecha
sin entrar en detalles respecto a
errores que son de ráfales garrafales
por ejemplo se eliminó cualquier mención
al terrorismo partiendo de la base de
que el terrorismo es solamente un
problema respecto de los pueblos
pueblo mapuche de ciertos grupos más
radicalizados pero le quita herramientas
de seguridad al gobierno por ejemplo en
caso de quien entrena chile células
terroristas e internacionales y no hay
ninguna mención al respecto lo cual en
términos de seguridad es una barbaridad
y lo dice felipe harboe ex miembro
subsecretario de michelle bachelet quien
fue presidenta socialista por lo tanto
quien no diga a claudia que este es un
tema de derecha porque hoy en día en
rechazo que es transversal no así de la
wta
bueno pues como ustedes ven ahí hay
opiniones aquí divididas en torno a lo
que significa este borrador lo cierto es
que esto hace parte de un proceso
claudia que chile ha venido presentando
desde hace varios años por poner un año
del 2019 que empezó con este estallido
social
esto puede ser este plebiscito parte de
una transformación que está viviendo
chile
es este este plebiscito gane la
aprobación o no independiente pero
solamente haber hecho esta convocatoria
haber reunido a las personas que se
encargaron para redactar esta esta nueva
carta magna y que los ciudadanos hayan
salido a votar es un gran ejemplo
democrático de una salida institucional
que chile logra dar ejemplo en la región
como valorar esa transición ese proceso
que ha llevado a cabo este país para
salir de ese estallido social
o sea esto es un ejemplo de la
democracia lo que hemos vivido acá en
chile esto es un ejemplo de que a pesar
de que tuvimos años
con miedo la gente lo perdió salió a la
calle a reclamar sus derechos y este es
el resultado y por eso todo el mundo
tiene los ojos puestos en chile por este
proceso que se ha llevado primero el
plebiscito de salida sea perdón de
entrada que ganó por un amplio margen
y la convención donde es la convención
fue paritaria con escaños reservados los
pueblos indígenas y por lo tanto el
resultado de aquello efectivamente es de
la gran mayoría que fue mandatada a
redactar una nueva la propuesta
constitución todos los artículos de que
tuvieron mayoría más de no recuerdo
cuántos personas de cientos tres creo
105 al menos que es el piso para probar
cada artículo entonces cuando me dicen
que esto no fue construido en igualdad
las votaciones eran bastante amplias
para poder aprobar cada artículo y los
artículos que no se aprobaron y que no
hubo acuerdo obviamente no quedaron en
esta nueva propuesta y ahora así
haciendo un paréntesis con lo que
nombraba y manuel
si efectivamente hay gente que
pertenecía a la democracia cristiana oa
sectores cercanos como él decía al
partido socialista
efectivamente han y se han desmarcado de
esta campaña de la prueba ahora y eso es
básicamente por lo mismo que tenemos la
constitución de ahora es porque ellos
quieren mantener sus privilegios no
quieren que los privilegios sean para el
pueblo la riqueza en la quiere seguir
concentrando un grupo de personas el
grupo más rico de chile ese 1% de la
población
el 17% de la población chilena vive es
de clase media-alta
y el 3 por ciento es el más rico y las
grandes fortunas están en el 1%
por otro lado que dicen que el tema de
que se quita el tema del terrorismo ojos
y la delincuencia y el terrorismo como
lo llama y el conflicto indígena
está por esta constitución no por la
nueva o por la nueva propuesta porque
todavía no se ha aprobado claro entonces
ahí
me gustaría que por favor
habláramos con claridad en ese sentido
entendiendo que además los medios hagan
chile los concentra
unos pocos y que efectivamente son
amanecer
por los grandes grupos económicos del
país qué bueno que usted toca ese tema
claudia mano es quiero hablar justamente
de cómo ha sido las campañas de
información a lo largo de estas semanas
allí en chile ha habido muchos
señalamientos en torno a la
desinformación que ha habido en las
redes sociales que justamente los medios
de comunicación pertenecen a grandes
conglomerados económicos que responden a
intereses empresariales y algunos de
ellos están concentrando mucho poder en
diferentes medios de comunicación creen
ustedes que aquí la desinformación jugó
un papel fundamental en a la hora de
contarle a los chilenos de qué se trata
o ustedes creen que los chilenos están
informados y están al tanto de la gran
responsabilidad que tienen en sus manos
para votar en este plebiscito con un
comienzo con manual
bueno yo creo que una clara demostración
de la falta de información es lo que
dice claudia ella claramente no ha leído
el texto no tiene absolutamente
conocimiento de nucleares falencias de
seguridad porque lo que acaba de decir
demuestra que no ha leído el texto y en
ese sentido yo creo que es más que los
medios de comunicación es que ves que ha
hecho el gobierno es tan escandalosa el
link el nivel de campaña que ha hecho el
gobierno para para intentar impulsar la
opción de apruebo incluso el tiempo
presidente ha salido a respaldar la
opción de forma pública
ministros en horario de trabajo han
realizado campaña abierto ha sido
logrado por ejemplo respecto al ministro
de giorgio jackson que es una persona
más cercana al presidente boris por
contraloría general de la república y
que es el órgano que controla al
ejecutivo y es más incluso el partido de
claudia por colocación el frente amplio
que apoyan al presidente boris acaban de
emitir hace tres semanas atrás una
declaración en la cual reconocían muchas
de las cosas que el gobierno había dicho
que eran fake muse respecto a muchas
materias por ejemplo que no hay línea
propia respecto a los problemas del
consentimiento indígena
respecto al tema de la dirección de
salud respecto a temas de tensiones
entonces una parte importante de la
izquierda radical está desesperada
puesto que este texto es sumamente
extremo y han tratado de debilitar a
cualquier opción o cualquier
interpretación distinta a la de ellos de
efectivos que están en el nivel de baja
calidad que tiene este texto que el
parqueo socialista no solamente
reconoció daños errores en una
declaración sino que incluso su
presidenta la señora abogada no sé
algunos ex profesionales como el señor
césar valenzuela salieron la reconocían
que acá la extrema izquierda se dio
muchos pulpos eso de no está claro
primer lugar que acá ellos no están
totalmente conforme con este texto y
demuestra que es un texto de baja
calidad por lo tanto se hace muy difícil
comprender de que ellos aprueben un
texto que ya lo están criticando incluso
antes de sobrar claudia su opinión hubo
desinformación se ha usado esto para
hacer campaña de un lado del otro a
propósito de este plebiscito
sí por supuesto pero antes que antes de
dar mi opinión quisiera pedirle a manuel
que no ponga palabras en mi boca y que
no diga que yo no he leído el texto yo
no soy ninguna ignorante soy un miembro
de la comisión política del partido
socialista y llevo una trayectoria de
muchos años en aquello y también he
visto como la derecha sobre todos los
poderes fácticos de este país le han
mentido sistemáticamente al pueblo
y eso es por ejemplo que llevan a las
televisiones porque como pertenecen a
estos grandes conglomerados que los
dueños son los más ricos de chile y
donde abiertamente dicen 6 news o
noticias falsas como por ejemplo que les
van a quitar las casas eso es mentira
que la casa usher ed hable y un montón
de cosas y son incluso han repartido
impreso unos libritos así donde dicen
que las cosas de la nueva constitución
donde nada de aquello se menciona en el
texto escrito
pero más allá de que los medios de
comunicación es que hayan
hayan desmarcado o por así decirlo el
contenido de la nueva constitución y
hayan hecho en una campaña en contra de
nuestra opción que es el apruebo
la gente si de alguna u otra forma se ha
querido informar las largas filas para
leer el nuevo texto de la constitución
donde se repartió gratuitamente como
campaña informativa si eran de cuadras y
cuadras ahora yo también le quiero decir
al ex constituyente de que declaración
me está hablando
donde nosotros nos dijimos de cosas
porque como son miembros de la comisión
política soy una de las personas que
tiene que aprobar las declaraciones del
partido socialista
y entonces a ese nivel vamos a llegar
entendiendo que la derecha de chilena
está usando las mismas campañas del
miedo del terror que se usaron en el 88
y la misma estrategia que utilizó trans
en eeuu y bolt sonaron razón
claudia en ese orden de ideas y con lo
que usted manual cuentan entonces sí o
no los chilenos están preparados para
esta votación si el conocimiento del
texto hay entendimiento del texto cuál
es su opinión
bueno yo creo que sí el chileno está
preparado para estar para esta votación
y se han dado cuenta que esta es una
constitución que no pone sobre la mesa o
no pone como prioridad sus principales
demandas por ejemplo de dónde vengo soy
un claro ejemplo de uno de los tantos
problemas que tiene esta constitución se
abrió el espacio para que personas
condenadas a delitos graves obre en el
caso del narcotráfico por ejemplo que
sean condenadas a menos de cinco años o
narcotraficantes que cumplan su condena
pueden ser candidato a presidente de la
república eso es algo gravísimo
gravísimo que se les pasó en la
discusión constitucional que han tratado
de guardarlo bajo cuatro llaves y así
muchos otros temas relativos también al
tema del sistema político que genera un
parlamento que le da prioridad a las
zonas más densamente poblada iniesta a
las regiones en desmedro
con con un sistema político que no calza
pues ninguna parte de lo cual ha sido
criticado por muchas personas de
centroizquierda por lo tanto claudia y
existen argumentos muy generales muy
pasivos y no va al texto no va a
argumentos de
pero habla de derechos sociales pero no
habla cómo se van a financiar y bueno yo
creo que por eso también la misma
presidenta del partido de claudia ya
está preparando al parecer cada tema por
siga en rechazo porque ellos saben que
realmente este proceso no lo satisface
de hecho parte importante de los
senadores del partido socialista que
están muy conformes probablemente no lo
dicen públicamente pero estoy convencido
que muchos de ellos van ahora rechazó
que claudia le duramente banal pero
justamente la descentralización no era
uno de los puntos clave de estos
reclamos ciudadanos de estos grandes
reclamos que había desde las diferentes
regiones de chile que todo está
exageradamente concentrado en santiago y
a lo largo y ancho del país pues falta
dar un poco más de autonomía
bueno en ese sentido la
descentralización las matas porque si tú
eliminas en el senado el senado es una
cámara de representación territorial
y en cambio la cámara de diputados es
una una una cámara en la cual se
representa las densidades poblacionales
por lo tanto en esta estructura de
sistema político se le da se le dan
amplias facultades a ese congreso de
diputadas y diputados lo cual va a
aumentar la trascendencia política de
los sectores densamente poblados como es
la capital santiago en primero en las
regiones por lo tanto de regionalismo no
hablemos porque la eliminación del
senado va en un sentido totalmente
contrario la representación que van a
tener a las reacciones en el congreso va
a ser muy disminuida y la cámara en la
región es que este nuevo órgano que
armar un poco un congreso express no va
a tener casi atribuciones xerente a
dicho congreso diputada diputado sin
claudia algo que decir sobre este tema
adelante
sí
sí por supuesto
en cuanto a este tema yo creo que
la cámara del senado efectivamente
hay que cambiarla la mayoría y muchas
veces la los cambios que se han querido
hacer en este país ha sido aprobada por
la cámara de diputados pero ha sido
rechazada por los senadores senadores
que además en su gran mayoría
aquí estamos con cosas
también quieren cuidar su privilegio
ahora el partido socialista tanto como
todos sus militantes están comprometidos
con la campaña de la prueba
por lo tanto insisto lo que viene a
traer esta nueva constitución es lo
mismo que tú decías recién es la
descentralización que no todo se
concentra en santiago sino que además
está la cámara de diputados- y las
cámaras de regiones donde este proyecto
lo que quiere es empoderar por así
decirlo a cada territorio regional
y en este sentido nosotros si lo vemos
con muy buenos ojos
ahora
por lo tanto creo que
[Música]
más allá de que como manuel decía de que
habló de generalidades es entiendo que
esto es un tiempo acotado y no vine a
leer cada capítulo de la constitución si
es que tenemos problemas para conectar
su vídeo su señal de vídeo entonces
vamos a solucionarlo con el equipo
técnico para para restablecer la imagen
mientras tanto continuó con manuel
hablando sobre sobre este tema manuel a
esta altura del partido cuando ya están
a pocas horas de comenzar las votaciones
para este a más una votación que es
obligatoria para todos los chilenos hay
todavía muchas críticas a la convención
si están todos verdaderamente
representados en este grupo de personas
que participó en la redacción de esta
convención porque todavía hay
señalamientos cuando ya pues el producto
está hecho la constitución está escrita
y ya va para aprobación
bueno acá hay una cosa que es muy clara
se habla de mucha democracia de
representación pero si tú empieza a ver
la forma en la cual se fue se fue
desarrollando el proceso tienes muchos
resabios autoritarios que están mucho de
la democracia o agresiones a
convencionales constituyentes hubo
amenazas de muerte convencionales
constituyentes no se respetaron los
reglamentos internos en muchas las
normas que se aprobaron y por sobre todo
parte importante estela del sector
político en chile fue vetado no
solamente la centroderecha la derecha
más dura sino que también parte
importante de la centroizquierda no fue
escuchar en estar en esta propuesta
lamentablemente como aquí se requerían
dos tercios para la aprobación de las
normas el partido comunista junto con
los escaños reservados de pueblos
indígenas y otros sectores de extrema
izquierda configurar un tercio del
bloqueo lo cual le impidió
el frente amplio del partido socialista
buscar un nexo hacia el centro y
lamentablemente ellos se dieron ante la
extrema izquierda llegando a este
resultado que es lo que yo creo está
ayudando a la ciudadanía a rechazarlo
porque es un texto que excluye a
sectores importantes dentro de la
política activa
manuel usted menciona la palabra rechazo
le pregunto a claudia la que puede ser
tal vez la pregunta del millón de
dólares qué pasa si es tan borrador no
es aprobado si no pasa en ese en ese
plebiscito
y la verdad es que nosotros estamos
convencidos que vamos a ganar este
domingo porque creemos que nuestro
pueblo tiene memoria y que necesitamos
un país y un chile más justo no no hemos
puesto en ningún caso en qué pasará si
perdemos nosotros estamos convencidos
que ganamos el domingo
y manuel cuál es su opinión si esto no
llega a ser aprobado no pasa el
plebiscito que escenario entonces viene
para chile y que tanto le puede pasar
esto factura al gobierno de turno el
gobierno del presidente gabriel boric
que sobra decir que simplemente está
llevando a cabo un requerimiento
ciudadano él no es impulsor de esto
porque su gobierno pues empezó
recientemente pese a que él hizo parte
de esos grupos estudiantiles que
participaron en el estallido social que
se puede decirles como el origen de todo
este este entramado
bueno en primer lugar si te rechaza la
propuesta constitución hoy por hoy es
más fácil en generar cambios con la
constitución actualmente vigente que con
el borrador puesto que el borrador
presenta cuero muy alto presentó un
forum de 4 céntimos más referéndum o de
dos tercios del parlamento más
consentimiento indígena en muchas
materias lo cual hace sumamente
complicado modificar la propuesta de
constitución por lo tanto yo creo que en
ese sentido del punto delta político es
muchísimo más simple
intentar y reimpulsar el proceso
constituyente mediante una reforma al
artículo 142 de la actual constitución
lo cual permitiría buscar una
alternativa y una salida a un proceso
constituyente que pueda entregar una
propuesta más sensata que eso sí
efectivamente yo creo que parte
importante también de trasfondo esto va
a ser una crítica a la pésima gestión
del gobierno de ciudad boris un gobierno
que ha tomado jugó por primera vez en
muchos años algo que no se había visto
ha tomado un partido hacia un sector del
plebiscito de forma escandalosa con
intervencionismo tremendo al punto tal
de contraloría ingreso a las oficinas de
la maneja el palacio presidencial para
requisar equipos e investigar en 10.000
preferencias en hockey y eso yo creo que
acá parte importante la responsabilidad
que le dan allá en los sectores que
están llamados a entregar un texto
moderado tiene ese sector está el frente
amplio que parte de ese el gobierno de
gabriel boric independiente no neutral
ya un grupo independiente que se vendió
a la extrema izquierda y parte
importante del colectivo socialista
especialmente los profesionales jóvenes
quienes fueron incapaces de buscar mano
en una moderación dentro de la
convención en claudia ya vamos llegando
al final del programa quiero preguntarle
si esto le pasa factura al presidente
boris en caso de no ser aprobado en el
plebiscito que tanto le pesa él este
legado que puede dejar para su gobierno
la aprobación o no de este borrador
o sea yo insisto yo no me pongo en la
postura de que vamos a perder el domingo
tomando un poquito en cuenta las
palabras de manuel el tema de la
contraloría efectivamente se hicieron
investigaciones investigaciones que la
contraloría anunció que habían llegado a
su fin y no había nada fuera de la norma
el gobierno solo hizo lo que es informar
y poner a disposición de todo el pueblo
chileno
y cuál era la nueva propuesta que había
salido de la convención constitucional
alavesa para que no quede allí una
nebulosa que acelerar hay algo para lo
que no es absolutamente falso y tú estás
diciendo que un programa miento de
contraloría respecto de el incautamiento
de equipo se son mentiras contraloría se
pronunció respecto a una campaña
informativa específica pero la
investigación respecto del reclutamiento
de equipos no ha llegado a su conclusión
y aún no se han intentan en por lo tanto
aclaremos seamos precisos y no engañemos
a la gente que está había
engañado al pueblo por 30 años
exquisitos alpes a la verdad el
pronunciamiento de la contraloría no es
respecto a la investigación general por
lo tanto te invito a informarte y a
decir las cosas como corresponden no a
señalar que el negociado en la misma
invitación a la invitación hablar de
las pueblas es que actualmente no se
están reconociendo y esta constitución
si reconoce y nacionalidad si reconoce
que en chile existen
manuel como en otros países y se los
reconoce sus derechos además como vemos
hay muchas discrepancias en torno a este
texto se nos acaba el tiempo aquí
podríamos quedarnos ir viendo las
diferentes aristas y muchos puntos que
plantea este borrador de la constitución
a claudia de manuel les agradezco por
haber estado con nosotros haber hecho un
panorama general de la situación en
chile declara a este plebiscito debo dar
paso al informativo se me acaba el
tiempo gracias a ustedes por la sintonía
sigan con france24
[Música]